je trouve qu'on est quand même assez dur
avec
Julie nous non pas pas vous mais je
trouve Guillaume voilà je trouve que
malgré tout en fait on rel relatez rien
pouriss il y a une plignante y a mise en
cause donc on va laisser faire la
justice d'ailleurs jula dit dès le début
quand elle est venue la première fois
sur le plateau masqué on va laisser
faire la justice mais malgré tout il
faut quand même comprendre que
globalement les femmes qui parlent même
si voilà ça nous met mal à l'aise
globalement les femmes qui parle et ben
elles disent souvent la vérité voilà
donc il faut quand même le dire je ne
vois pas ce que ce que Julie a à gagné
justement qu'est-ce que ça t'a apporté
DEP qu'est-ce que Julie a gagné à part
un énormément d' merde en fait qu'est-ce
que ça t' apporté depuis Julie passe à
autre chose une libération une
libération parce que ça fait 10 ans que
je dis rien ça fait 10 ans que je me
suis persuadée que c'était presque moi
la coupable je me suis mis euh ma
famille presque je dirais ma famille às
il disent quoi ils disent quoi ta
famille aujourd'hui il ils se sentent
coupable ah ouais maintenant ils se
sentent coupable parce que ma sœur a
prévenu et malheureusement bah moi je je
l'ai pas écouté j'y suis j'ai continué
elle a alerté mes parents qui m'ont fait
confiance et parce que cyil
pardonnez-moi mais dans ce genre de
fonctionnement évidemment qu'il y a de
la fascination pour la vedette
évidemment qu'il y a de l'acilération
évidemment qu'il a de l'emprise
évidemment qu'après on dit ah mais
peut-être qu'il faut faire ça pour pour
être connu pour travailler à la télé ou
pour travailler à la radio donc
peut-être qu'il y a aussi tout ça je ne
sais pas je connais pas le dossier donc
je pense que aussi quand on est regardé
nous par aussi des jeun qui écrivent à
des gens qui sont connus à des gens qui
qui sont dans le spectacle et tout ça il
faut aussi leur dire ça que voilà elle
peut aussi je ne sais pas si vous vous
dites la vérité où vous montez mais ça
peut aussi participer à un système de de
prédation et tout ça donc il faut quand
même faire très attention aussi et pas
tout de suite la cabler en disant en
gros tu veux quoi la notoriété tu veux
la tune ouais mais
attends
don
j'ai POS cette question dit j'ai été
contacté par un avocat qui a dit que un
vous ne connaissiez pas son adresse et
de que vous lui aurez vous lui auriez
demander combien vous pouviez récupérer
d'argent à vous de me dire si c'est vrai
ou faux il y a deux version dité fa
voilà après le téléphone de Julie tu me
dis si je me trompe il a été
perquisitionné donc il y a tout un tas
d'éléments aussi que la police a en sa
possession sur des échanges qui pourrai
être aussi délictueux donc ça c'est la
police de faire de faire son travail moi
je sais que j'ai vu quelques é ch c'est
à la police de voir si ces échanges à
l'âge où tu que tu as sont tu as eu tu
as eu les les les les les avocat
et qu' ont l'air sur de sur de et c'est
pour ça et c'est pour ça même l'avocat
hier il a l'air vraiment extrêmement et
c'est pour ça que c'est très bien que
Julie soit là pour répondre point par
point sur bande organisée extorsion je
ne veux pas d'argent c'est pour ça que
c'est très clair et qu'elle a tout à
fait le la latitude et que Julie a
toujours voulu acceptter même pas voulu
que les deux versions puissent être
présenté et là c'est très bien parce
que
Guillaume guum ils sont obligés aussi de
demander à Julie rel rien du tout tu dis
un mail que tu as vaguement reçu d'un
avocat Mme
lé me est
suxoc avocat
séri avocat conna qui est très sérieux
quioc sérieux est pas série ce qu' fa
c'est pas bien ce que tu dis Galine
arrête truc mais n'importe quoi
Géraldine tu vois bien qu'il y a deux
versions contradictoires donc Julie est
là pour donner sa version des faits et
c'est très bien on l'écoute et Julie
elle même l'a dit il a la préstion
d'innocence il faut écouter la version
de qu de ses avocats c'est pas bien le
procè que tu es en train de nous faire
gérardine ça n'a rien à voir et moi
j'avais une autre question hier l'avocat
de de de coé a sous-entendu était pas
très clair làdessus d'ailleurs sur les
conversations sur les SMS soit qu'ils
étaient faux soit qu'ils auraient été
modifiés vous vous maintenez que ces
conversations sont réelles qu'elles
n'ont pas été tronqué qu'il y a pas de
messag supr elles ont pas été truqué ces
ces ces messages là et de toute façon
quand on fait une comme tu as pu le dire
quand on se fait perquisitionner son
téléphone il retrouve absolument tous
les échanges et tous les messages
supprimés donc même si j'en avais si je
si tout le monde suppose que j'en ai
supprimé ils sont retrouvés donc moi
j'ai donné mon téléphone en toute
tranquillité ok mais moi j'ai pu
visionner des choses c'est pas c'est pas
enfin il y a il y a rien de supprimé
effectivement quand on voit une capture
d'écran on peut se dire qu'il y a
quelque chose qui a été supprimé moi
j'ai vu les textos il y a pas il y a pas
de de de choses
supprimées rien de d'accord g Julie au
fil de l'enquête vous serez auditionné
et puis il y aura une confrontation avec
Sébastien cet est-ce que vous êtes prête
à cette confrontation je me suis pas
posée encore la question je je je je
commence à me préparer doucement parce
que je sais que ça va ça arrivera oui
mais c'est vrai que c'est vrai que je
suis assez assez sensible encore à tout
ça et j'ai pas j'ai peur de j'ai un
petit peu peur c'est vrai sur l'idée de
la confrontation je su un petit peu
après on on est représenté je suppose
hein je mais Julie vous avez euh peur
oua vous étz vous étiez voilà fan de ce
métier euh voilà vous voulez absolument
devenir animatrice en radio vous avez
côtoyé d'autres animateurs euh voilà que
vous avez été voir dans le public que
vous avez oui ça
c'est il y a jamais eu de problème non
absolument pas je j'ai fait plein de
j'ai fait plein de plateaux comme je
l'avais déjà dit j'étais venu vous voir
sur Europe 1 ça j'avais été j'avais fait
c'est quelou enfin j'avais fait plein
plein d'émiss étes venu nous voir vous
étiez venu dans le clip aussi avec nous
c'est ça et d'autres animateurs auss
jamais de pas non il y avait pas que
Monsieur cé absolument pas mais c'était
c'est vous en fait vous étiez fan de
beaucoup d'animateurs vous étiez surtout
fan de Cé j'étais fan de de l'émission
j'étais fan de de l'émission de ce qu'il
faisait après lui il était beaucoup plus
accessible puisque on discutait donc
bien sûr que j'allais le voir euh assez
souvent
ouais bien sûr parce que lui en fait il
donnait l'impression il plus accessible
que que moi par exemple voilà mais c'est
parce que vous voir voilà ouais oui bien
sûr puisque lui après quand il donne son
numéro quand il donne son snap enfin je
veux dire c'est qui discute bah viens me
voir je vais t'aider qui donne des
conseil et cetera bah aprs on a plus la
facilité d'aller ver énergie ouais
aujourd'hui vous êtes déçu de ce métier
je je dirais pas que tout le monde est
comme ça mais oui ça m'a beaucoup déçu
ou ça m'a beaucoup déçu et maintenant je
travaille dans le médical
vous je sais ce que ce que je fais ça
aide vraiment les gens vous êtes plus
heureuse oui avant ou maintenant vous
avez vous avez parlé alors je dirais pas
que je suis plus heureuse parce que bon
maintenant le enfin mon travail est au
courant je veux dire que ça m'a mis un
peu comme dis bien Géraldine j'ai tout à
y perdre moi mentir j'ai tout à y perdre
bien sûr donc j'ai absolument aucune
raison deourage votre entourage et même
les les les vos collègues ils disent
quoi ils vous soutiennent ils disent
quoi mes collègues me soutiennent mon
entourage aussi
après après c'est c'est quand même très
difficile parce que dans le milieu
médical on voit beaucoup de monde donc
c'est vrai que aujourd'hui vous avez
montrer votre visage à énormément de
monde c'est la première fois que je le
fais ou parce que il circulit sur les
réseaux sociaux mais jamais voilà aussi
voilà aussi exposé euh demain donc il y
a encore des gens qui vont vous en
reparler vous l'avez fait aussi pourquoi
pour parce que vous pour montrer que la
parole en fait on doit on doit plus
avoir peur et que c'est important de que
c'est important de parler alors je dis
pas d'aller parler dans les médiia si
ces personnes-là ne veulent pas le faire
elles peuvent le faire directement en
gendarmerie ou à la police appel le
parquet elles peuvent se rendre en
gendarmerie mais il faut montrer que en
fait toutes ces accusations là c'est
c'est enfin pour moi c'est pour faire
peur et j'ai j'ai plus peur et je ne
veux plus avoir peur j'ai eu assez peur
je je veux dire avant même que que ce
soit révélé sur Twitter en mon nom
propre j'avais j'étais passée par un
compte un compte anonyme j'ai reçu quand
même un appel d'une fausse avocate et ça
je pense que personne enfin c'est
bizarre personne n'en parle mais j'ai
reçu un appel d'une fausse avocate vous
l' dit sur twitterou mais bon mais
personne ne se mais personne ne revient
là-dessus mais j'ai été intimidée
d'accord j'ai été intimidée et il faut
plus en fait avoir peur j'ai eu peur non
parce que mais j'ai mais j'ai eu très
peur au départ je me suis dit jamais je
pourrais aller porter plainte je me suis
dit mais c'est pas possible je je j'ai
trop peur ils vont venir chez moi j'ai
commencé à flipper et finalement je me
suis dit mais pourquoi pourquoi pourquoi
avoir peur tu vas te rendre en
gendarmerie et justement c'est eux qui
vont qui vont faire la lumière sur cette
histoire et je leur fais entièrement
confiance puisque je leur ai donné mon
téléphone et qu'ils l'ont extrait donc
pour moi il y a
absolument oui puis merci Julie merci
désolé il est 21h18 merci Julie d'avoir
été avec nous merci Miriam de votre
témoignage tout de suite c'est mon
juille sur C8
merci